INTRO:
Can you guess
what the third largest automaker in the world is?
Volkswagen? GM? Daimler? While those are all
great guesses and would usually be correct, we’re
not living in normal times. Last week, the third
most valued automaker in the world was actually
Rivian. Rivian peaked at a valuation of $150
billion which is more than Volkswagen. Volkswagen
generally delivers a cool 10 million cars per
year. Considering this, how many cars do you think
Rivian delivers? 8 million? 5 million? Well, the
answer is actually a whopping 156 pickup trucks.
Now, I don’t wanna bag on Rivian because they’ve
worked super hard on their pickup truck over
the past decade and they’ve had to cross so many
hurdles to get to market. Moreover, they actually
have a great working product unlike some other
notable competitors. So, there’s nothing wrong
with the company Rivian, but there’s no doubt
that there’s something seriously screwed up with
the stock Rivian. So, here’s the story of Rivian
and how they became the epitome of the EV bubble.
QUIET BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back, when Rivian was founded in
2009, most people didn’t really care about EVs.
EVs were completely impractical due to their low
range and high cost. Hybrids were starting to pick
up steam but this was only in what most would
consider the nerd community. So, Rivian didn’t
particularly have a bright outlook out the gate,
but that didn’t stop a man named Robert Scaringe
or RJ from taking the risk anyway. At the time, RJ
was only 26 years old and he had spent his whole
adult life in academia. RJ had a bachelors in
mechanical engineering from Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute and a PHD in mechanical engineering from
MIT. But instead of continuing on in the regular
path and getting a job, after graduation, RJ
returned to his home state of Florida and founded
Mainstream Motors. Some sources say that RJ came
up with the capital himself, but at 26 with most
of his life spent in academia, it’s not likely
that he would’ve been able to come up with
car company levels of startup capital.
I’m sure RJ put in every penny he had,
but most of the money for initial development came
from the Florida government. You see, RJ’s father
Robert Scaringe Sr. was a business owner himself
who ran a company called Mainstream Engineering.
I think you can see where RJ got the name
Mainstream Motors from. But anyway, his father
had managed to raise $61 million over 25 years all
from the US government. So, his father was well
aware of how to raise money, and given that the
US government was looking to support EV endeavors,
RJ was able to secure a small grant of 2 million
dollars. Given that he was building a car from
scratch though, this really didn’t last that
long. RJ ended up spending $900,000 on payroll,
$170,000 on contractors, and the rest was
presumably on materials and manufacturing.
By 2011, RJ had burned through all the money,
but at least he had something to show for it.
Mainstream Motors had created an electric
sports car called the R1, but there was a
massive problem: the Tesla roadster. RJ’s sports
car wasn’t bad by any means, but the Roadster was
already on the road and it didn’t make sense to
compete against Tesla in an already niche market.
I’m not sure why RJ didn’t realize this
when he started the project as Tesla was
delivering roadsters since 2008. But, he did
eventually make this realization and he would
decide to scrap the entire idea. Now, I’m
sure people are going to comment down below
that Rivian is considering bringing back this
car today, so it wasn’t a waste. But in 2011,
the revival of this car was by no means a
guarantee. So, RJ was back to ground zero.
CHANGING COURSE:
Determined to change the direction of the
company, RJ looked at what EV competitors
weren’t targeting, and the obvious
answer was SUVs and pick up trucks.
RJ also decided to change the name of the company
to Rivian which was derived from Indian River.
He combined the first part of River and the
last part of Indian. RJ had spent a lot of his
childhood in a rowboat on the Indian River in
Florida, hence the name. Anyway, RJ had a new
target and new name, but he was still lacking the
biggest part which was new funding. For RJ though,
this wasn’t that hard to secure. The source of
Rivian’s 2012 funding effort isn’t clear, but it
was likely the government again or some venture
capitalists who like to keep a low profile.
Over the next couple of years, Rivian hired a
bunch of talent from legacy automakers like Ford,
GM, and Chrysler, and by the end of 2016,
they had grown to 100 employees. This is still
relatively small, but given that basically all
of these guys were engineers earning 6 figures,
it wasn’t cheap to run Rivian. Even if we
just assume $100,000 per year per person,
we’re looking at $10 million annually
on just payroll. And keep in mind,
Rivian still had no revenue coming in. Rivian was
also investing heavily into manufacturing plants.
For example, in January of 2017, Rivian acquired
a manufacturing plant from Mitsubishi for $16
million. Soon enough, Rivian revealed their pickup
truck and their SUV originally called the A1T
and the A1C at the LA Auto Show in November
of 2018. Unlike the Cybertruck reveal which
left the audience divided, the A1T and A1C were
exactly what the audience wanted. From a distance,
they looked just like traditional vehicles, but
up close, they had that futuristic electric touch,
and that’s what made all the difference. Step
by step, Rivian was slowly getting ready to
launch their first vehicle, but the last step
of bringing the product to market would take
way longer and cost way more than anybody
expected. Fortunately for Rivian though,
investors with massive pockets would
enter the scene after this reveal.
SMART MONEY:
Up until this point, Rivian had primarily
raised money in the tens of millions,
but it didn’t take long for them to cross into
the hundreds of millions. In May of 2018, Rivian
took on $200 million worth of debt from Standard
Chartered bank which increased their total raised
funds to a whopping $450 million. Despite raising
nearly half a billion dollars, the general public
still wasn’t that interested in EVs as the price
was still way out of reach for most people. But
all of this would change with the launch of the
Tesla model 3 in 2017. While the Tesla model 3 was
a promising idea from the start, many big players
weren’t convinced that Tesla would actually
be able to execute on the idea. And this was an
absolutely fair assessment given that Tesla would
go through production hell in 2018 trying to ramp
up the model 3. Tesla played with the bankruptcy
line several times this year, and there were
plenty of customer complaints regarding subpar
manufacturing. Despite all the uncertainty though,
Tesla survived 2018, and that was the signal
that the time for EVs had finally come. Many big
players didn’t want to take the gamble with Tesla,
but now that Tesla had gotten to the otherside,
they were willing to take the risk with other EV
startups. And this led them straight to Rivian.
In February of 2019, Amazon led a $700 million
investment round for Rivian. Overnight Rivian
went from lifetime fundraising of $450 million
to raising $700 million in a single round and this
was just the beginning. Just two months later,
Ford invested $500 million which they would
later raise to $1.2 billion. Later that year,
Cox Automotive poured in another $350 million.
And Amazon would put the nail in the coffin by
ordering 100,000 electric delivery vehicles from
Rivian. By the end of 2019, Rivian had raised
a total of $2.85 billion, and now that smart
money was in, it was time to open up the gates.
EV BUBBLE:
As we all know, starting at the end of 2019, Tesla
stock soured. First it crossed a $100 billion,
then it overtook Volkswagen and Toyota, and now
it’s literally a trillion dollar company. That’s
more than the rest of the top 10 auto companies
combined. I’m not trying to get into whether
that’s justified or not, but something that’s
crystal clear is the fact that Tesla took the rest
of the EV industry with them and that of course
includes Rivian. In the meantime, Rivian was
struggling to start production and get deliveries
going. Promised delivery dates and came and went,
and Rivian kept delaying the release time after
time. But one thing we can be sure of was that
money was no longer the issue. They had already
raised billions, and billions more were flowing
in due to Tesla hype. But Rivian was running out
of time. Ford had revealed their F150 lightning
and Tesla was rapidly building their Austin
gigafactory and making the cybertruck a reality.
It would’ve been a shame if Rivian had targeted
the EV pick up truck and SUV market a decade ago
just to beat by Tesla and Ford. Fortunately
for Rivian though, they were able to deliver
at the last second. At the end of August, Rivian
filed for an $80 billion IPO and this confirmed
that Rivian was finally ready to start making
deliveries. Ironically, despite targeting the
market years before Ford and Tesla, it looks like
they only beat them to market by months. Anyway,
by the time Rivian IPOd, they had raised
a total of $10.5 billion since 2019 alone.
To put that in perspective, that’s half the
valuation of Nissan, twice the valuation of Mazda,
and four times the valuation of Aston Martin.
And all of that was just to get their first
product to market. But looking back, that
was just a drop in the bucket given that they
would reach a valuation of $150 billion which
just leaves the question, what happens next?
FUTURE OF RIVIAN:
The truth is Rivian’s entire existence has been a
bubble. First it was millions from the government,
then it was tens of millions from early investors,
then it was hundreds of millions from smart money,
and now it's billions from the public markets.
It seems like this must come to an end soon, but
the truth is, that’s not necessarily the case. All
it takes is one announcement from Elon that Tesla
is going to do a stock split on December 9, and
Tesla and EV industry will go to Mars. If Tesla
makes another run, I wouldn’t be surprised if
Rivian ends up overtaking Toyota which is stupid
but reality nonetheless. When the bubble does
eventually pop though, whether that's tomorrow or
after Rivian reaches a trillion dollar valuation,
retail investors will likely lose substantial
amounts of money. Instead of trashing on Rivian
and shorting the stock though, I think it's a much
better idea to see it in a positive light. The EV
bubble has given companies that would otherwise
have little chance against the legacy automakers
an opportunity. And at the end of the day,
the bubble is centered on a great cause which
is reducing pollution and transitioning to
sustainable energy. The more companies that
enter the scene and fight for market share,
the faster we’ll see a transition to EVs. So,
maybe the bubble isn’t actually all that bad.
The crash, however, will be deadly for Rivian
if they don’t make a mark before it’s too late.
So, I wish the best to Rivian despite their
stupid valuation, but only time will tell if
they’re able to make it to the other side. Do
you guys think Rivian will survive the eventual
crash and rival Tesla? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you also have a love hate
relationship with the EV bubble. And of course,
consider joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.